Are you afraid of heights? Do you hyperventilate at the thought of a flu shot? Do you go out of your way to avoid elevators and other small enclosed spaces? Have you driven across the country because you're too frightened to fly? Or avoided a particular driving route because you're terrified of bridges? All of these are examples of what psychologists call specific phobias, which constitute one of the most common forms of anxiety disorder. studies have found that anywhere from 9% to 13% of people experience a specific phobia at some point in their lives.
您有恐高症吗？一想到打流感疫苗就会过度换气吗？您是否会特意避开电梯和其他狭小的封闭空间？您是否因为害怕飞行而选择横跨全国的自驾游？或者因为极度恐惧桥梁而避开特定的行车路线？所有这些都是心理学家所称的“特定恐惧症”的例子，它是焦虑症中最常见的形式之一。研究发现，9% 到 13% 的人在其一生中的某个阶段会经历特定恐惧症。
And unfortunately, although effective treatments are available, far fewer people receive treatment than could benefit from it. So what are phobias and how do they differ from fears? What are some of the most common phobias and how common are they? Where do phobias come from? Are you born with them or are they learned? What treatments are available for phobias and how well do they work? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
遗憾的是，尽管目前已有有效的治疗方法，但获得治疗的人数远少于能够从中受益的人数。那么，什么是恐惧症？它与恐惧有何不同？最常见的恐惧症有哪些？它们的普遍程度如何？恐惧症从何而来？是天生的还是后天习得的？有哪些治疗恐惧症的方法？效果如何？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Martin Antony, a professor in the Department of Psychology at Toronto Metropolitan University. He also holds part-time or adjunct faculty appointments at McMaster University and the University of Toronto, and he was the founding director of the Anxiety Treatment and Research Clinic at St. Joseph's Healthcare in Hamilton, Ontario. Dr. Anthony is internationally known for his books and research on anxiety disorders, including phobias, as well as perfectionism, cognitive behavioral therapy, and assessment of psychological disorders. He has published 33 books, including several evidence-based self-help manuals for the general public on overcoming phobias and anxiety.
我是主持人金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。今天的嘉宾是多伦多都会大学心理学系教授马丁·安东尼（Dr. Martin Antony）博士。他还在麦克马斯特大学和多伦多大学担任兼职或客座教职，并曾是安大略省汉密尔顿市圣约瑟夫医疗中心焦虑治疗与研究诊所的创始主任。安东尼博士因其在焦虑症（包括恐惧症）、完美主义、认知行为疗法以及心理障碍评估方面的著作和研究而享誉国际。他已出版了 33 本书，其中包括多本面向大众、基于证据的自助手册，旨在帮助人们克服恐惧症和焦虑。
Dr. Antony is a fellow of the Royal Society of Canada and a past president of the Canadian Psychological Association. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Anthony. My pleasure. Thank you for inviting me to be here. Let's start by talking about the difference between a fear and a phobia. A phobia is just a more extreme type of fear, or are they more complex than that? So a phobia is a fear that, first of all, is excessive. So it's out of proportion to the actual danger in the situation. But it's also a fear that is causing problems for a person.
安东尼博士是加拿大皇家学会会员，也是加拿大心理学会的前任主席。感谢您今天参加我们的节目，安东尼博士。不客气，很高兴受邀来到这里。让我们先从恐惧和恐惧症的区别谈起。恐惧症只是恐惧的一种极端表现，还是说它们比这更复杂？恐惧症首先是一种过度的恐惧，即与情境中的实际危险不成比例。但同时，这种恐惧也正在给当事人造成困扰。
So it's maybe bothering them that they have the fear. Or it's interfering with their life in some way. So you may be terrified of snakes. But if you never see a snake, it doesn't really affect what you do in your day-to-day life. Then who cares? You just have a fear of snakes. On the other hand, if you can't leave your house because you might see a snake, and your fear of snakes is affecting your ability to enjoy a movie or a TV show
也就是说，这种恐惧可能让他们感到苦恼，或者在某种程度上干扰了他们的生活。比如，你可能非常害怕蛇，但如果你从不接触蛇，这并不会真正影响你的日常生活，那又有什么关系呢？你只是对蛇有恐惧感。另一方面，如果你因为可能看到蛇而无法出门，或者你对蛇的恐惧已经影响到你欣赏电影或电视节目的能力，
because there might be a snake on there, or you're having nightmares about snakes that are keeping you awake, then it might be at a level that we might call a phobia. So that's one common phobia, snakes, but what are some of the other common phobias and what are the triggers for these phobias? Is there something that ties them together, particularly? Yeah, so the most common phobia is most likely animal phobias. So spider, snakes, dogs, cats, birds, mice. And often among animal phobias, the ones that are most common are the fears of creepy, crawly kinds of things like mice and spiders and snakes and things like that. Heights would be probably the second most common. So that's very common as well. But we also see lots of people with a fear of flying, a fear of enclosed places, blood, needles, a fear of being in water, fear of storms.
因为节目里可能会出现蛇，或者你因为做关于蛇的噩梦而失眠，那么这种程度可能就被称为恐惧症了。蛇是常见的恐惧症之一，那么还有哪些常见的恐惧症？它们的诱因是什么？它们之间有什么特别的联系吗？是的，最常见的恐惧症很可能是动物恐惧症。比如蜘蛛、蛇、狗、猫、鸟、老鼠。在动物恐惧症中，最常见的是对那些令人毛骨悚然的小动物的恐惧，比如老鼠、蜘蛛和蛇等。恐高症可能是第二常见的，也非常普遍。此外，我们还看到很多人患有飞行恐惧症、幽闭恐惧症、血液恐惧症、针头恐惧症、恐水症和风暴恐惧症。
So lots of different things, but those are some of the more common ones. And all of these, if you're phobic, it impairs your life, right? I mean, it's not just that you're worried that a hurricane is coming because it really is coming, but that you spend a lot of time dwelling on this, ruminating over, there's going to be a storm. Oh, my God, I can't go anywhere. Yeah, so some of the people I've seen who come for treatment of storm phobias, it's affecting their life in a few ways. So, first of all, they're constantly monitoring the weather channel, for example, and on days that there are possible storms or even just maybe rain forecast. They may not go to work on those days.
所以种类繁多，但这些是比较常见的。如果患有恐惧症，它会损害你的生活，对吧？我的意思是，这不仅仅是因为飓风真的要来了而担心，而是你花了很多时间纠结于此，反复思虑“会有风暴，天哪，我哪儿也去不了”。是的，我见过一些来治疗风暴恐惧症的患者，这在几个方面影响了他们的生活。首先，他们会不断监测天气预报，在可能出现风暴甚至只是预报有雨的日子里，他们可能就不会去上班了。
And then when there is a storm, they may have to hide in their basement so they don't see the, lightning through the window and they have the music blaring so they don't hear the thunder. So it affects their ability to make plans and do the things that they want to do. And yeah, so it's affecting their life. And that's what brings people in for help. Where do phobias come from? Do people just have a bad experience at some point early in life, like say a turbulent flight that then leads to fear of flying?
当风暴真的来临时，他们可能不得不躲在地下室，这样就看不到窗外的闪电，还要把音乐开得很大声，这样就听不到雷声。这影响了他们制定计划和做自己想做事情的能力。是的，这确实影响了他们的生活，这也是人们寻求帮助的原因。恐惧症从何而来？人们是否只是在生命早期的某个时刻有过糟糕的经历，比如一次颠簸的飞行导致了飞行恐惧症？
Or are the origins of phobia less clear cut than that? Yeah, so I think it really depends on the person. So different people have different pathways to developing fear. So three pathways that have been identified. One is a negative experience in the situation. So people have a direct learning experience. So maybe they've been bitten by a dog or been in a car accident that leads to a fear of dogs or fear of driving. But we can also develop phobias through modeling. And modeling basically just involves watching other people. So learning through observations. So if you You grow up with parents who are terrified of driving and you see their fear year after year, you know, by the time you get your license, you know, you might be at a higher likelihood of having a fear of driving just from watching them be afraid for so long. So we know that children often learn to be afraid by watching other people's responses and situations. A third pathway is through information or instruction. And this is learning through language, things that people tell. us. So if our parents are always warning us to be careful when we're driving because, you know,
还是说恐惧症的起源并不那么明确？是的，我认为这确实因人而异。不同的人有不同的恐惧形成路径。目前已确定了三种路径。第一种是情境中的负面经历，即人们有直接的学习体验。比如，可能被狗咬过或经历过车祸，从而导致对狗或驾驶的恐惧。但我们也可以通过“模仿”产生恐惧症。模仿基本上就是观察他人，即通过观察来学习。如果你在父母对驾驶极度恐惧的环境中长大，年复一年地看到他们的恐惧，那么当你拿到驾照时，你因为长期观察他们的恐惧行为，患上驾驶恐惧症的可能性就会更高。我们知道，孩子们往往通过观察他人在特定情境下的反应来学会恐惧。第三种路径是通过信息或指导，这是通过语言学习，即别人告诉我们的事情。比如，如果我们的父母总是警告我们要小心驾驶，因为“你永远不知道会发生什么”。或者媒体当然也会导致人们产生各种恐惧。这可能是形成恐惧的第三种路径。但我还要补充一点，这些路径对每个人的影响并不相同。两个人可能都经历过车祸，一个人产生了驾驶恐惧症，而另一些人则没有。所以我们知道，还有其他因素，比如遗传，会增加我们在经历这些事件后产生恐惧的脆弱性。
you never know what's going to happen. Or the media certainly can contribute to different fears that people have. That could be a third pathway to developing fear. So but I'll just add, those pathways don't affect everybody equally. So two people can have a car accident. One person develops to fear of driving and one doesn't. So we know that there are also other factors, things with genetics, for example, that increase our vulnerability to developing fear following one of these events.
（注：此段落原文在第8段末尾与第9段开头有重叠，已按逻辑顺延）
And the last thing I want to mention is the role of what we call preparedness. And all that means is that through evolution, presumably we are prepared or predisposed to learn to fear some things more, easily than others. So just as an example, almost nobody has a fear of flowers. But it's very common to have fears of spiders and snakes. And the thinking is that spiders and snakes prehistoricly would have been more dangerous to our ancestors than flowers would be. Even modern threats,
我想提到的最后一点是所谓的“准备性”（preparedness）的作用。这意味着通过进化，我们可能已经准备好或预先倾向于更容易学会对某些事物产生恐惧。举个例子，几乎没有人会害怕花朵，但害怕蜘蛛和蛇却非常普遍。人们认为，在史前时代，蜘蛛和蛇对我们的祖先来说比花朵更危险。即使是现代威胁，
like an electrical socket, theoretically, electrical sockets can be dangerous. But we don't see a lot of people with phobias of electrical sockets. And again, the thinking is that we haven't developed that, kind of put that propensity to develop that fear through evolution because they just haven't been around for that long. So there's our learning plays a role, but so does our genetics and so does just how we're built in terms of how we've evolved to be more careful around things. that are potentially threatening and things that have been threatening for thousands and tens of thousands and hundreds of thousands of years.
比如电源插座，理论上电源插座也可能很危险，但我们并没有看到很多人患有电源插座恐惧症。同样，人们认为这是因为我们还没有通过进化形成那种产生恐惧的倾向，因为它们出现的时间还不够长。所以，学习起着一定作用，但遗传以及我们如何进化以对潜在威胁事物保持警惕，同样起着作用。这些威胁在成千上万年甚至几十万年的时间里一直存在。
So let's talk about treatment for a minute. What are some of the ways that you can help people overcome phobias? What is based on scientific evidence that has been shown to work? So the most effective treatment is exposure therapy. So we have all benefited from exposure to overcome a fear of one thing or another. One thing I would ask the audience to do is to reflect on is there anything in their life that they used to be afraid of that they're not afraid of anymore. And it might be maybe when there were kids, they were afraid of the dark and now they're not. Or maybe the first day at work at their job, they were very nervous meeting new people.
让我们谈谈治疗。有哪些方法可以帮助人们克服恐惧症？哪些是基于科学证据并被证明有效的？最有效的治疗方法是暴露疗法。我们都曾受益于暴露疗法来克服某种恐惧。我想请听众反思一下，生活中是否有曾经让你害怕但现在不再害怕的事情。也许小时候你怕黑，但现在不怕了；或者第一天上班时，你对结识新同事感到非常紧张。
Or the first time they went on a date with their partner, they were very nervous. And it just got easier over time. And I might ask them, why did it get easier? And usually the answer is, well, I just had to do it. And it got easier. I got used to it. I learned that the situation wasn't dangerous. And that's what exposure therapy is all about.
或者第一次和伴侣约会时，你非常紧张。但随着时间的推移，一切都变得容易了。我可能会问他们，为什么变得容易了？通常答案是：“我不得不去做，然后就变得容易了，我习惯了，我意识到这种情况并不危险。”这就是暴露疗法的核心。
We come up with a plan where people gradually expose themselves to the situation or the object that they're afraid of at their own pace. We don't force people to do anything. And again, it's done gradually. People start at a place what they're willing to. and as they become more comfortable, they try things that are more challenging. So for phobias, that tends to be the main component of treatment. There are other strategies that may be useful as well, but that would be the most important one for specific phobias in particular.
我们制定一个计划，让人们按照自己的节奏逐渐暴露在他们害怕的情境或物体中。我们不会强迫任何人做任何事。同样，这是循序渐进的。人们从他们愿意尝试的地方开始，随着他们变得更加舒适，他们会尝试更具挑战性的事情。对于恐惧症来说，这往往是治疗的主要组成部分。虽然还有其他策略可能有用，但对于特定恐惧症而言，这是最重要的。
Now, with exposure therapy, is that something you can do on your own, or do you need a professional to help you? That is a great question. So I get asked all the time, if I read your... your self-help book on how to overcome a phobia, will I overcome it? And my answer is, it's always the same. I say, yes, in the same way that if you read a book on physical fitness, you'll get physically fit. So in other words, reading the book isn't going to get you over your phobia.
那么，暴露疗法是你可以自己做的，还是需要专业人士的帮助？这是一个很好的问题。人们经常问我：“如果我读了你写的关于如何克服恐惧症的自助书，我能克服它吗？”我的回答总是相同的。我说：“可以，就像如果你读了一本关于健身的书，你就能变得健康一样。”换句话说，光读这本书并不能让你克服恐惧症。
You have to do all the things that the book describes. And some people are able to do that. I get emails from people all over the world who said that the strategies in the book change their lives. but we also know from research that many people cannot do it on their own or completely on their own. They need the support of a therapist who can help to motivate them, help to solve any problems that come up. In the case of animal phobia, you often need someone else to be controlling the animal and holding the animals because the client who's afraid of dogs can't go out and find dogs themselves
你必须去做书中描述的所有事情。有些人能够做到。我收到过来自世界各地人们的电子邮件，说书中的策略改变了他们的生活。但我们也从研究中得知，许多人无法完全靠自己做到。他们需要治疗师的支持，治疗师可以帮助激励他们，帮助解决出现的任何问题。在动物恐惧症的情况下，你通常需要另一个人来控制动物，因为害怕狗的客户自己无法去寻找狗，
or spiders or whatever. So having somebody there, whether it's a family member or therapist, to help control the environment and offer support, can be useful. So I guess the quick answer is some people are able to do on their own. Other people need the support of a therapist or family member, somebody to work with them in the situation. Are there some phobias that are harder to get over than others, or does it really just depend on the individual who has the phobia? Yeah. I think it depends a lot on the individual. So I've seen lots of people with the same fear who respond differently to treatment. It does, one thing I would say is that the type of fear does impact on how long it takes to get over it. So there are studies with animal phobias showing that in about two to three hours of exposure, even in a single session, the majority of people can overcome the fear.
或者蜘蛛之类的。所以，有个人在场，无论是家人还是治疗师，来帮助控制环境并提供支持，都是有用的。所以我想简短的回答是：有些人可以自己做到，而另一些人则需要治疗师或家人的支持，需要有人在情境中与他们一起工作。有些恐惧症是否比其他恐惧症更难克服，还是说这完全取决于患者个人？是的，我认为这很大程度上取决于个人。我见过许多患有同样恐惧症的人对治疗的反应不同。有一点我想说，恐惧的类型确实会影响克服它所需的时间。有研究表明，对于动物恐惧症，在两到三个小时的暴露治疗中，即使是在单次疗程中，大多数人也能克服恐惧。
In my experience with driving fears, it takes longer. So it might take me about 10 weeks with somebody where they're practicing a lot in between sessions as well to get to that same point. The other thing I would say is that although most people with a specific phobia can overcome the fear through treatment, more complex kinds of problems like social anxiety where people are nervous in a wide range of social situations. that can take longer to overcome. And it's not unusual for people to be doing much better at the end of treatment, but still struggling with social anxiety from time to time. So it's often a less complete recovery than it would be with something like an animal phobia or a height phobia.
根据我的经验，驾驶恐惧症需要更长的时间。我可能需要花大约 10 周的时间，让患者在疗程之间进行大量练习，才能达到同样的程度。另外我想说的是，虽然大多数患有特定恐惧症的人可以通过治疗克服恐惧，但像社交焦虑这样更复杂的问题，即人们在广泛的社交场合感到紧张，可能需要更长的时间才能克服。治疗结束时，人们的情况好转很多，但偶尔仍会受到社交焦虑的困扰，这种情况并不罕见。因此，与动物恐惧症或恐高症相比，这种恢复往往不那么彻底。
I'm curious about fear of flying as one example, because, I mean, you could go through a lot of the steps that you outline in your books and your manuals. And, I mean, it just seems really tough if you get to the point where you're on an airplane and you have a panic attack, essentially, you can't get off the plane. I mean, how do you work up to getting over fear of flying, which can be very intense for people? Yeah, so people are afraid of flying for different reasons. So for some people, it's a fear of the plane crashing. They're not afraid of having a panic attack. They're afraid of the plane itself.
我对飞行恐惧症很好奇，因为你可以按照书中的步骤进行，但如果你到了飞机上并产生恐慌发作，基本上你就无法离开飞机了。对于那些对飞行有强烈恐惧的人，你是如何帮助他们克服的？是的，人们害怕飞行有不同的原因。对一些人来说，这是对飞机坠毁的恐惧，他们并不害怕恐慌发作，他们害怕的是飞机本身。
For other people, they are afraid of having a panic attack. So I've had, you know, one person said when I'm, when I'm on a plane and I'm feeling frightened, I wish the plane would crash. You know, for that person, it's not a fear of the plane. It's a fear of how they feel on the plane. So again, having a panic attack and not being able to escape. And if that's the case, we can often treat people on the ground. Because people who are afraid of panicking are also afraid of other situations often where they might panic and not be able to get out, like an enclosed place, for example. and they're afraid of the panic symptoms themselves. So we can encourage people to experience those symptoms, hyperventilate, you know, breathing really quickly, for example,
对另一些人来说，他们害怕的是恐慌发作。我曾遇到过一个人说：“当我在飞机上感到害怕时，我希望飞机坠毁。”对那个人来说，这不是对飞机的恐惧，而是对在飞机上那种感觉的恐惧。所以，再次强调，如果是因为恐慌发作且无法逃脱，我们通常可以在地面上治疗患者。因为害怕恐慌的人通常也害怕其他可能导致恐慌且无法离开的情境，比如封闭空间，而且他们害怕恐慌症状本身。所以我们可以鼓励人们体验这些症状，例如过度换气（呼吸非常快），
to get lightheaded or spinning around to get dizzy or running on the spot to get their heart racing. And what we find is that as people become less afraid of the symptoms in general, those people also become less afraid of flying because of those, you know, when it is due to that fear of symptoms. And there are also strategies we can use with a fear of panicking that can be other strategies like cognitive strategies where we teach people to identify and challenge some of the thoughts underlying the fear.
以感到头晕目眩，或者通过旋转来感到眩晕，或者原地跑步来让心跳加速。我们发现，当人们对这些症状不再那么恐惧时，他们对飞行的恐惧也会减轻。此外，对于恐慌恐惧，我们还可以使用其他策略，比如认知策略，教导人们识别并挑战恐惧背后的某些想法。
A lot of people may believe that the sensations are dangerous, for example. So we can help people to reinterpret those sensations as an experience that we all have, but not one that's dangerous necessarily. So there are other tools we can use as well in addition to just exposure. Do people who have phobias and use exposure therapy and then feel like they're better, do they have to do some kind of maintenance? I mean, do you have to keep practicing in order for the phobia not to recur? So fear can return, and there are different factors that might contribute to return of fear.
许多人可能认为这些感觉是危险的。因此，我们可以帮助人们将这些感觉重新解读为我们都会有的体验，而不一定是危险的。所以，除了暴露疗法之外，我们还可以使用其他工具。患有恐惧症并使用暴露疗法感觉好转的人，是否需要进行某种维护？也就是说，为了防止恐惧症复发，是否需要持续练习？是的，恐惧可能会回归，有不同的因素可能导致恐惧复发。
One is a very long period of not encountering the situation. Another is having a traumatic experience in the situation. So if you've overcome your fear of driving, then you get into a car accident. You might be more likely to have a return of fear. So we do encourage people to continue some maintenance exposure to when they have an opportunity to encounter the situation to do that. The other thing I would say is when we are doing therapy, we often encourage people to continue the exposure, even beyond what they might need to get. by in everyday life so that if a little bit of the fear does return, they can, it's manageable. So just as an example, if I'm working with somebody with a fear of spiders, you know, we would
一个是长时间没有接触该情境。另一个是在该情境中经历了创伤性事件。如果你克服了驾驶恐惧症，然后发生了车祸，你复发的可能性可能会增加。因此，我们确实鼓励人们在有机会接触该情境时，继续进行一些维护性的暴露练习。另外，在进行治疗时，我们通常鼓励人们在日常生活中超越所需的程度继续进行暴露练习，这样如果恐惧稍微回归，他们也能应对。举个例子，如果我正在帮助一个患有蜘蛛恐惧症的人，我们
begin with them standing a few feet away from a spider in a jar and they get closer and eventually hold the jar and then eventually open the jar and spill the spider into a tub and eventually poke the spider. By the end, they're typically holding the spider, even though nobody needs to hold a spider in their everyday life. But if they don't see a spider for a year or and a little bit of that fear comes back, there's room for that without it interfering with their life again. And I should mention we don't use dangerous spiders for any of these. Right, of course, of course. Yeah, we're in Canada. We don't have to worry as much about that, but I know that there are people in the audience who have to be careful with the spiders they might
会从让他们站在离罐子里的蜘蛛几英尺远的地方开始，然后他们会靠近，最终拿着罐子，最后打开罐子把蜘蛛倒进盆里，甚至去触碰蜘蛛。到最后，他们通常会拿着蜘蛛，尽管日常生活中没人需要拿着蜘蛛。但如果他们一年没见到蜘蛛，恐惧稍微回来了一点，他们也有空间去应对，而不会再次干扰他们的生活。我应该提到，我们不会在这些练习中使用危险的蜘蛛。当然，当然。是的，我们在加拿大，不必太担心那个，但我知道听众中有些人必须小心他们在家中可能
encounter their homes. Now, I know in recent years has been a growing interest in using virtual reality for exposure therapy. What are the advantages and the disadvantages of VR and is it as effective as real world exposure therapy like you just described? Yeah. So the great thing about virtual reality is that you can do it in the therapist's office. And before long, people are going to have access to be able to do this in their homes. In fact, there may already be options where people can just get the software on their own. And we know that people can buy the head mounted displays from, you know, Oculus.
遇到的蜘蛛。近年来，人们对使用虚拟现实（VR）进行暴露疗法越来越感兴趣。VR 的优缺点是什么？它是否像你刚才描述的现实世界暴露疗法一样有效？是的。虚拟现实的好处在于你可以在治疗师的办公室里进行。不久之后，人们将能够在家里进行这种治疗。事实上，可能已经有选项可以让人们自己获取软件。我们知道人们可以从 Oculus 那里购买头戴式显示器。
And I think Apple is putting something out next year. at least that's what the rumors say. So it will become increasingly accessible and inexpensive over time. The other nice thing about it is that it's just easier. If you're afraid of flying, it's not practical to fly three times a week, but you could be in a virtual airplane three times a week. And there are data to support virtual reality for a range of problems. I'd say that some of the strongest studies in specific phobias have been in height phobia.
而且听说苹果明年也会推出相关产品。所以它会变得越来越容易获得且价格低廉。另一个好处是它更方便。如果你害怕飞行，每周飞三次是不现实的，但你可以在虚拟飞机上每周练习三次。有数据支持虚拟现实在解决一系列问题上的有效性。我认为在特定恐惧症中，最强有力的研究是在恐高症和
and flying phobias that have found them to be useful. There's also data supporting it for public speaking phobias. And the studies that have compared it to live exposure have generally found it to be about equally effective. And there is a caveat that I want to add is that most of these studies or many of these studies have been done by scientists, researchers who run virtual reality therapy clinics. So their clients are very invested in virtual reality and they are excited about virtual reality. So there may be a bit of a bias in that way in terms of who they're studying. I can tell you that in my own experience at our clinic, we found virtual reality to be helpful,
飞行恐惧症方面，研究发现它们是有用的。也有数据支持它在公共演讲恐惧症中的应用。将它与现实暴露进行比较的研究通常发现它们的效果大致相当。但我需要补充一个警告：大多数或许多这些研究是由经营虚拟现实治疗诊所的科学家和研究人员完成的。所以他们的客户对虚拟现实非常投入，也非常兴奋。因此，在研究对象方面可能存在一定的偏差。我可以告诉你，根据我在我们诊所的经验，我们发现虚拟现实很有帮助，
but probably not as helpful as the real thing. So again, that's just more anecdotal. But the research generally has supported it. And I would say we need to see more research and we need to see research in, and maybe other types of settings as well where maybe clients are not. Again, if you're going to a VR clinic, you're going to be really excited about doing VR, maybe more so than doing non-VR exposure.
但可能不如现实世界的效果好。这只是轶事证据。但研究总体上支持它。我认为我们需要看到更多的研究，也需要在其他类型的环境中进行研究，也许那里的客户并不像 VR 诊所的客户那样对 VR 感到兴奋。
Sure. Yeah. Is there a particular age when phobias are likely to develop? Yeah, it really varies across phobias. So things like animal phobias and storm phobias begin very early. In fact, a lot of people will say, I've had this for as long as I can remember. They have no memory of how it started often.
当然。是的。恐惧症是否有特定的发病年龄？是的，这在不同的恐惧症之间差异很大。像动物恐惧症和风暴恐惧症在很小的时候就开始了。事实上，很多人会说：“我记得我有这个恐惧症已经很久了。”他们往往不记得它是如何开始的。
At the other extreme would be something like claustrophobia. So it's much more unusual for a young child to be afraid of enclosed places. That on average tends to begin more in the sort of when someone's in their 20s on average. It can begin younger. But the average age of onset is much older for claustrophobia. So driving phobia obviously can't begin until you're old enough to drive. So just by definition, just in terms of licensing laws and things. So there are some differences.
另一个极端是幽闭恐惧症。幼儿害怕封闭空间是非常罕见的。平均而言，这种情况往往在一个人 20 多岁时开始。虽然也可能更早开始，但幽闭恐惧症的平均发病年龄要大得多。驾驶恐惧症显然要等到你达到驾驶年龄才能开始。所以根据许可法律等定义，确实存在一些差异。
But for sure, some phobias begin very young. What about sex differences? I was wondering if there might be some phobias that women might have more than men or maybe men are socialized to hide their phobias. And so we don't really know what the incidence is. Yeah, that's a great question. So if we just look at the data on prevalence, across men and women, there are differences.
但可以肯定的是，有些恐惧症在很小的时候就开始了。那么性别差异呢？我想知道是否有些恐惧症女性比男性多，或者男性是否被社会化要求隐藏他们的恐惧症，所以我们不知道实际的发病率。这是一个很好的问题。如果我们只看患病率数据，男性和女性之间确实存在差异。
So some phobias like animal phobias and storm phobias, again, are much more common in women than men. Other phobias like blood and needle phobias are about equally effective. Some studies have found that we have slightly more effective in women than men, but I would say it's generally much closer compared to something like an animal phobia. But to your second question, do, is it possible that men are just underreporting phobias? And there is an older study that looked at that, that found exactly that. What they did is they had people report on phobias,
有些恐惧症，如动物恐惧症和风暴恐惧症，在女性中比男性更常见。其他恐惧症，如血液和针头恐惧症，发病率大致相当。有些研究发现女性的发病率略高，但我认为与动物恐惧症相比，差距要小得多。关于你的第二个问题，男性是否只是少报了恐惧症？有一项较早的研究对此进行了调查，结果正是如此。他们让人们报告恐惧症，
and they found what we typically find, that women were more likely to report having these fears than men. But then they brought them back a few weeks later and did the same questionnaire, but this time they hooked them up to these electrodes, and they told them it was a lie detector test. They told them we're going to know whether you're telling the truth. And what they found is that women's fear levels were rated at about the same level, but men reported their fears of snakes and spiders and so on as higher when they thought they were going to be caught.
结果发现我们通常看到的情况：女性比男性更容易报告有这些恐惧。但几周后，他们把这些人叫回来，做了同样的问卷，但这次给他们接上了电极，并告诉他们这是测谎仪测试。他们告诉受试者：“我们会知道你是否在说实话。”结果发现，女性的恐惧水平评分大致相同，但男性在认为自己会被识破时，报告的对蛇和蜘蛛等的恐惧程度更高。
So anyway, it suggested that men might not be as comfortable reporting their fears unless they know that they're going to be caught. I should say that with any kind of research, this is so important is that we replicate findings. There was another study that did not replicate that findings. So we really, for any kind of research, we can't rely on one study. We need to wait until there's three or four or five or six studies and look at the pattern across studies. So there, there's kind of mixed findings right now. And if there are, the other question that's relevant, though, is why are there these gender differences? So one possibility is that men are underreporting their fear.
总之，这表明男性可能在知道自己会被识破之前，并不愿意报告他们的恐惧。我应该说，对于任何研究，重复研究结果都非常重要。有另一项研究没有重复出这一发现。所以对于任何研究，我们都不能依赖单一研究。我们需要等待有三、四、五、六项研究，并观察跨研究的模式。目前研究结果比较混杂。如果存在性别差异，另一个相关的问题是：为什么会有这些性别差异？一种可能性是男性少报了恐惧。
But another possibility is just our social learning. So I know when I was growing up, it wasn't unusual to see a woman standing on a chair screaming if there was a mouse in the room, whereas you wouldn't see that with a man. And men might also be socialized, not to be afraid. Maybe they're teased more if they show fear of something. So they force themselves to do it, whereas in a little girl, that might be more acceptable. So the thinking is that to the extent that there are gender differences, and it has more to do with our learning and our socialization than anything to do with
但另一种可能性是社会学习。我知道我成长过程中，看到一个女人在房间里有老鼠时站在椅子上尖叫并不罕见，而男人则不会这样。男性也可能被社会化要求不要害怕。也许如果他们表现出对某事的恐惧，会被嘲笑得更多。所以他们强迫自己去做，而对于小女孩来说，这可能更容易被接受。因此，人们认为，如果存在性别差异，这更多与我们的学习和社会化有关，而不是与
biological differences or anything like that. Yeah, that makes sense. So we've talked about common phobias, but what are some of the most uncommon phobias? I mean, what is like the strangest phobia you've ever encountered in your work? Yeah, so I guess one thing I would say is as common as these common phobias, are it's also common to have uncommon phobias. So lots of people have phobias that other people don't have. So it might be a very specific kind of insect,
生物学差异有关。是的，这很有道理。我们谈到了常见的恐惧症，那么一些最不常见的恐惧症是什么？你在工作中遇到的最奇怪的恐惧症是什么？是的，我想说的是，虽然常见恐惧症很普遍，但拥有不常见的恐惧症也很常见。很多人都有别人没有的恐惧症。比如对某种特定昆虫的恐惧，
like I've seen people with a fear of moths. I saw somebody with a fear of buttons, like closed buttons, that if they encounter buttons, they would become very frightened and they would avoid them. In every way, it was similar to a spider phobia or something in that it was very specific. to that one situation. It's not like they were generally anxious or anything like that.
我见过有人害怕飞蛾。我还见过有人害怕纽扣，那种扣子，如果他们遇到纽扣，就会变得非常害怕并避开它们。在各方面，这与蜘蛛恐惧症类似，因为它非常针对那一种情况。他们并不是普遍焦虑。
We once saw somebody who was afraid of the airplanes flying overhead. They could be in an airplane. That wasn't frightened to them. But if an airplane was flying overhead, they were frightened. And they were carrying an umbrella. And if the umbrella was open, they felt protected. And I don't know if it's because the umbrella blocked the vision, like they weren't able to see the airplane or if they were afraid something
我们曾经见过一个人害怕头顶飞过的飞机。他们可以坐飞机，那对他们来说并不害怕。但如果飞机在头顶飞过，他们就会害怕。他们随身带着一把雨伞。如果雨伞是撑开的，他们就感到安全。我不知道这是因为雨伞挡住了视线，让他们看不到飞机，还是因为他们害怕有什么东西
was going to fall out of the plane. like, I don't know what, they didn't even know what the fear was. They just knew that they were afraid. They would panic if an airplane flew overhead. And if they had an umbrella open, they were less afraid. So those are just a few examples. But again, people can be. And actually, I did mention that fear of flowers is very uncommon.
会从飞机上掉下来。我不知道恐惧的根源是什么。他们只知道自己很害怕。如果飞机在头顶飞过，他们就会恐慌。如果他们撑开雨伞，恐惧感就会减轻。这些只是几个例子。但人们确实可以……事实上，我提到过对花朵的恐惧非常罕见。
We have seen two people with a fear of flowers. One of them had a fear of sunflowers. And she had an experience as a very young child, where she was in a sunflower field with her family, and she got separated from her family, and these tall sunflowers were blocking her ability to find her family, and she had a traumatic experience around sunflowers. The other one was afraid of hollyhocks,
我们见过两个害怕花朵的人。其中一个害怕向日葵。她在很小的时候有过一次经历，当时她和家人在向日葵地里，她和家人走散了，这些高大的向日葵挡住了她寻找家人的视线，她对向日葵产生了创伤性经历。另一个人害怕蜀葵，
so another very specific kind of flowers, and she had an experience when she was little, where she was chased. Somebody was chasing her and hitting her with hollyhocks. So she developed a very specific fear, also have a very specific flower. And from both of those cases, there was a traumatic experience that caused it. So, again, it's easier to learn to fear spiders or snakes or heights than some of these
也是一种非常特定的花，她小时候有过一次经历，有人在追她，并用蜀葵打她。所以她对这种特定的花产生了非常具体的恐惧。在这两个案例中，都有一个导致恐惧的创伤性经历。所以，学习害怕蜘蛛、蛇或高处比学习害怕这些更不寻常的东西要容易得多。但学习害怕这些东西并非不可能。所以，拥有某种不寻常的恐惧症并不罕见。而且，我在这里笑了一下，但我明白这是严肃的事情。我的意思是，这些人的生活因为恐惧而受到了影响，
other more unusual things. But it's not impossible to learn to fear these other things. So it's pretty, it's not unusual to have a fear of something that's unusual. And, you know, I'm laughing a little bit here, but I understand that this is serious stuff. I mean, these are people whose lives have been impinged upon because of the fears. and I don't want to discount that. I mean, this really is, we're not, you know, just being silly here. I'm not just being silly here, I should say.
我不想忽视这一点。我的意思是，这确实是……我们不是在开玩笑。我应该说，我不是在开玩笑。
Let me ask you, is there a relationship between specific phobias and other anxiety disorders like social phobia or agoraphobia, which for our listeners is just the fear of being in public or crowded spaces? Yeah, so we looked at this years ago. I think when I was still a graduate student in the 1990s, I think we published a paper on this. And what we found was that they often go hand in hand. It's not unusual for people to have a specific phobia as well as some other problem. But if the most severe problem that they have is a specific phobia, that tends to be the only thing they have. On the other hand, if the most severe anxiety problem they have is something else, like social anxiety or panic disorder, OCD or something, the specific phobia, they'll often have an additional specific phobia of,
让我问你，特定恐惧症与其他焦虑症（如社交恐惧症或广场恐惧症，对我们的听众来说，就是害怕在公共场合或拥挤空间）之间是否存在联系？是的，我们多年前研究过这个问题。我想我在 20 世纪 90 年代还是研究生时就发表过相关论文。我们发现它们经常相伴出现。人们同时患有特定恐惧症和其他问题并不罕见。但如果他们最严重的问题是特定恐惧症，那往往是他们唯一的问题。另一方面，如果他们最严重的焦虑问题是其他问题，比如社交焦虑、恐慌症、强迫症等，他们通常会伴随有程度较轻的特定恐惧症。
lesser severity. And the way we interpret that is basically to say that when specific phobias are, they tend to be less severe than some of the other anxiety problems. So when people do have both, it's the other problem that's usually the one that's interfering the most with their life. And that's why specific phobia is, even though they're the most common or among the most common anxiety problem that people can have, they're the least likely to show up for treatment. it. For most people, even though it interferes somewhat with their life from time to time, they can get by, whereas something like social anxiety might affect everything, their ability to form relationships, their ability to work, and things like that. A fear of spiders might affect
我们对此的解读是，特定恐惧症往往比其他焦虑问题严重程度更低。所以当人们两者兼有时，通常是另一个问题对他们的生活干扰最大。这就是为什么特定恐惧症虽然是最常见或最常见的焦虑问题之一，但他们最不可能寻求治疗。对于大多数人来说，尽管它偶尔会干扰生活，但他们可以应付，而像社交焦虑这样的问题可能会影响一切，包括建立关系的能力、工作能力等。害怕蜘蛛可能会影响
places you can go. It might keep you up at night sometimes, but it's not, the impact is more manageable than it would be for some of these other problems. On average, again, there's always exceptions. I've seen people with medical phobias, for example, who can't get life-saving surgery because their fear of needles or something like that. But for the average person with a specific phobia, they're more likely to make either not seek treatment because they're not sure where to get it or even if they know where they can get it. They'd rather just live with the fear. So what are the next big research questions for you? What are you looking at now? So a lot of my work is very broad.
你去的地方，可能会让你偶尔失眠，但其影响比其他问题更可控。当然，总有例外。我见过患有医疗恐惧症的人，因为害怕针头而无法进行救命的手术。但对于患有特定恐惧症的普通人来说，他们要么因为不知道去哪里治疗而不寻求治疗，要么即使知道去哪里，也宁愿忍受恐惧。那么你接下来的重大研究课题是什么？你现在在关注什么？我的工作范围很广。
So I'm not currently doing any work in specific phobias in particular currently. We're doing some research in perfectionism. We're doing some research on social anxiety. One of the studies that one of my graduate students is working on right now is looking at the relationship between experiences of racism and discrimination in black women and their impact on social anxiety. So that's one project going on in the lab. And then we have a couple of projects going on in perfectionism, looking at perfectionism in problem gaming, for example, looking at the impact of perfectionism in friendships. So we are, actually, we are developing a new
我目前没有专门针对特定恐惧症的研究。我们正在进行完美主义的研究，也在进行社交焦虑的研究。我的一名研究生目前正在进行的一项研究是观察黑人女性经历的种族主义和歧视与社交焦虑之间的关系。这是实验室正在进行的一个项目。我们还有几个关于完美主义的项目，例如观察完美主义在游戏成瘾中的表现，以及完美主义对友谊的影响。所以我们实际上正在开发一种新的
measure of specific phobias to measure severity. So this will be a tool that would be helpful for researchers to look at changes in specific phobia levels as a result of treatment. So that's That's ongoing right now. We've been doing some research on anxiety and COVID. So we did, I said I'm not doing work in specific phobias, but I am. We just finished a study. It's under review right now looking at claustrophobia and mask wearing during the COVID-19 pandemic. So that is a project related to specific phobias for sure.
特定恐惧症严重程度测量工具。这将是一个有助于研究人员观察治疗后特定恐惧症水平变化的工具。这是目前正在进行的工作。我们一直在做关于焦虑和新冠疫情的研究。我说我没有做特定恐惧症的研究，但我确实在做。我们刚刚完成了一项研究，目前正在审稿中，观察新冠疫情期间的幽闭恐惧症与佩戴口罩的关系。所以这绝对是一个与特定恐惧症相关的项目。
And then a lot of my time right now is spent. leading a provincial program here in Ontario aimed at getting evidence-based treatments for anxiety problems to people across the province in a stepped care model where people begin with a more self-directed approach and then step up to a therapist directed approach if needed. And, you know, the big challenge in anxiety, you know, we now have effective treatments and We're always tweaking them to see if we can get them a little bit better. But the biggest challenge is getting them to the people who need them. And that's what this other big project is, provincial project involves,
我现在大部分时间都花在领导安大略省的一个省级项目上，旨在通过阶梯式护理模式，为全省人民提供基于证据的焦虑症治疗。人们从更自主的方法开始，如果需要，再升级到治疗师指导的方法。你知道，焦虑症面临的最大挑战是，我们现在有了有效的治疗方法，我们一直在调整它们，看看能否做得更好。但最大的挑战是让需要的人获得这些治疗。这就是这个省级项目所涉及的内容。
seeing if we can get the help to people who need it the most. Well, I want to thank you for joining me today, Dr. Anthony. I think this is very interesting. And I appreciate that there are effective treatments. And I think we can put some information in the notes that go along with the podcast, directing people to some of the publications that you have out there that will tell people how to take care of themselves if they've got a phobia. Great. Thanks very much. I appreciate it. I really enjoyed being here and all the best. Thanks.
看看我们能否为最需要帮助的人提供帮助。安东尼博士，非常感谢您今天能来参加我的节目。我认为这非常有意义。我很欣慰现在已经有了有效的治疗方法。我想我们可以在播客的附注中提供一些信息，引导听众阅读您发表的一些文章，告诉他们如果患有恐惧症该如何自我护理。太棒了，非常感谢。我很感激。我很高兴能来到这里，祝一切顺利。谢谢。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 以及其他任何您收听播客的平台上找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。如果您喜欢我们的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作，我们的音频编辑是 Chris Kondyian。感谢您的收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。